Two thousand and 17 is coming to an end
and just before the year ends,
I'd like to say a big thank you from
everyone here at visual politic for
joining us each and every week.
Now,
having said that,
we want to end this year with what we
hope will be the start of a tradition.
So without further ado,
here are the 2017 visual politic awards.
First of all,
just a quick note it.
We decided to give out four awards
because there are four of us here at
visual politic.
It's like let's get into the.
Due to his growing leadership and strong
offensive civil rights.
One of the visual politic awards is for
Justin Trudeau.
Hi everyone.
I'm Justin Trudeau.
They denied the Canadian prime minister
has been one of the great protagonists
of 2017 and did we can say that it's
been a particularly busy year for
Trudeau,
a year in which this young politician
has become in the eyes of the world,
something of an anti trump and you're
not going to give you a question.
Can you stay category?
Are Fake News,
fake news,
fake news.
They are the enemy of the people this
morning.
Hey,
we have respect for journalists in this
country.
They asked tough questions and they're
supposed to stay in the last 12 months.
His actions in the field of human rights
have been quite extensive,
so how about we look at some examples?
Well,
the prime minister kicks off the year
with the welcome to Canada campaign,
which aims to welcome refugees and we
could say that he's really succeeded and
he's made the European Union look bad at
the same time because of that lack of
commitments on the issue.
In recent months,
Canadians have opened their hearts and
their arms to families fleeing the
ongoing conflict in Syria and from the
moment they arrived,
those 31,000 refugees were welcomed not
as burdens,
but as neighbors and friends as new
Canadians
in 2017.
He also gave honorary citizenship Canada
to the Nobel Peace Prize winner,
Malala Yousafzai,
a Pakistani activist who fights for
women's rights and who has been brutally
persecution and attacked by the Taliban.
He has also worked as hard as we saw in
the video on this channel on is
integration and recognition of the
indigenous people in Canada,
and last but not least,
in a historic speech you made before
parliament last November,
officially apologized on behalf of the
federal government for the repression
that the government's exercised against
members of the lgbt community until the
nineties.
We were wrong.
We apologize.
I am sorry.
We are sorry,
but
that's not all.
This year,
today's government has also reaffirmed
its intention to legalize the
recreational use of marijuana.
He has also announced that the
government will increase its number of
residency permits so that new immigrants
to the country in search of a better
future.
Honestly,
there's not much more you could ask for
in a single.
Yeah,
yeah.
Some of you might not be thinking,
well,
okay,
okay.
There's lots of civil rights stuff
signed it,
but couldn't this just be a distraction
from the state of their economy,
which really isn't working?
Well,
actually no,
because in matters of economy,
it's not actually looking at that
either.
The Canadian economy expects to close
2017 with three percent growth and it's
the lowest unemployment rates in 10
years.
Along these same lines,
in 2017,
Trudeau ratified his free trade
agreement with the European Union is
also set his sights on Asia,
especially China.
China will soon be the largest market in
the world.
It's home to 1 billion potential
customers for the high quality goods and
services that Canadians deliver every
day.
It's true that things are going slower
than expected,
but even so,
there's a very good chance that Canada
will end up becoming a great bridge
between the American and Chinese
economies.
Yes,
that is right folks,
and while we may not completely agree
with Justin Trudeau's agenda,
we do think that he is contributing to
the construction of a better world for
all.
So from all of us.
Congratulations Justin.
The next visual holistic award is for
fighting when the president of Taiwan
price is a bit special in somewhat
different because with we won't
recognize political success,
but rather the ability to resist.
Allow me to explain.
We decided to give this award to sighing
Wang for two main reasons,
first for being the first female
president of Taiwan and for being a
symbol to other East Asian societies.
I think the young people are generally
excited about this idea of hugging a
woman to lead the country.
I thought it was rather trending second
for her from will to defense Taiwan's
democracy and freedom in the face of
Beijing's desire for reunification
because let's not forget that this
country has one of the most flourishing
and alive democracies in the region,
and China,
as you may know,
is a dictator
to share
2017 has been a difficult year for the
islands and for its presidents.
China has unleashed a political and
economic war against Taiwan,
the likes of which has not been seen for
years.
There's all resulted in presidents size,
refusal to commit to the so called 1992
consensus and agreement under which
China is recognized as a single mom.
And of course if is clear it,
that all this economic and political
pressure poses a huge problem for this
country.
Forty percent of its exports currently
depends on mainland
China,
however,
the viewer fall from surrendering,
citing when this government has
reinforced it's political strategy to
sync and consolidate alternatives to
China,
mainly opening the Southeast Asian,
Australian,
and New Zealand markets.
This is known as the new southbound
policy and so far the results have been
pretty good.
Trade with these countries is growing
strongly at rates of seven percent at
the time.
Taiwanese economy is also regained some
vigor and investors have regained
confidence in this country.
This has resulted in quite a bit of
pressure on China so well even though we
don't like some of the things about
this.
Governments such as their slowness,
when facing reforms,
we really believe that their spirits of
resistance to Chinese pressure justifies
this truck.
Yep.
Fiction with Beijing may not be most
convenient for the islands interests,
but I think we need to make two things
clear.
First,
when we talk about resistance,
we're talking about protecting one of
the most democratic and liberal regimes
in Asia and seconds according to polls.
This policy is clearly backed by
Taiwanese society.
Due to all of this in when gets one of
this year's visual political wards,
so let's continue and this next award,
it doesn't just go to one politician,
but it goes to an entire political party
and this would be the check pirate
parties
zero,
and so now you might be wondering,
well,
why are we giving this award to the
check pirate?
Because they came in third in the track,
parliamentary elections that occurred
this year,
being the second most voted for pirate
party on the planet,
only surpassed by the Icelandic pirate
posy
to be answered here is,
well,
what does the Pirate Party stands for?
Wealthy pirates ideology,
or as they call it,
the pirate movements.
There was born in Sweden in the year
2005.
They wanted to protect online privacy
and to reform copyright laws.
This is why they're called the pirate
party according to them.
Copyright laws are needless barriers for
entrepreneurs can only help big
corporations.
Okay,
so just hold on a second year because I
know what you're thinking now.
Does this mean that we add visual
politic are against copyright and
Intellectual Property Law?
Well,
far from it because the truth is that
the pirate movements,
it has changed a lot since 2005.
Now their manifesto covers far more than
what it started with from economic
foreign policy.
See,
there's
now a big difference between the pirate
parties in different countries.
Just like a Swedish social democrat is
totally different from a Spanish Social
Democrats and Icelandic pirate is seldom
similar to a check pirate so well did
the check pirate stand for first of all,
tech lovers as they are,
they want to implement e-government
solutions in the same vein as Estonia.
It really makes absolutely no sense that
today in the 21st century,
you need to wait in line for more than
four hours in an administrative office
in order to report that you changed your
residence.
This happens today in the Czech Republic
and because I live here,
this is something I've had to do and it
is an enormous pain in the ass and isn't
this kind of bureaucracy madness.
It is not only time consuming,
but it's also a big share of the
government's budget is stonier has saved
millions thanks to these reforms and
they should be a model for other
countries plus the check pirates.
They stand for freedom of movement,
freedom of speech and fiscal
responsibility.
During their campaign,
they avoided the temptation of promising
more spending or giving grants to anyone
which was especially alluring in an
election full of populist candidates and
on top of all that,
all the ones that legalize weed
with this program,
the check pirates came in third in one
of the Czech Republic's most notable
elections in history.
Usually in most countries that are two
or three main political forces,
but not anymore in the Czech Republic.
First place went to Anodea lip and their
leader Andre Babish,
but he only obtained the less than 30
percent of the vote after him is the
sense of rights ods party who made up
the little more than 10 percent below
those with almost the same percentage.
There aren't pirates,
the virus,
the past,
other charismatic and radical
politicians like the communist party and
Mr Tom,
Joachim Mira and anti immigration
candidates.
Just as a funny note,
Mr Nakamura is actually originally from
Japan,
so when walking around Prague,
during the elections,
you could see a big picture of a
Japanese dude which says,
say no to immigration.
It was actually pretty funny.
So in other words,
the check pirates have obtained
surprising results with a solid and
rational manifesto.
Some of their proposals certainly better
than others,
but in general,
they deserve our applause.
Sire criteria.
Lemon nosheen Paretsky.
Last but not least,
the fourth award,
because he couldn't be left out of this
list,
goes to
Emmanuel macron make our planet.
You said that Mr Macron,
here's one of the biggest surprises of
the year.
First of all,
you had to create his own political
party from zero.
Yes.
You heard that right?
He started his political career as the
finance minister in the social
democratic government of manual valves,
but he was not affiliated with that
party.
He was an independent.
It's hard because of his achievements
working in the finance industry.
I want France to be a thought that
nation meaning both a nation is that we
end for the startups,
but also a nation that thinks and moves
like a and make
no mistake here.
He has not had an easy job.
France has been in crisis for years.
As we said in this other video.
The country used to be one of the
world's biggest economies,
but now it's companies find it hard to
compete in the international markets.
Part of this is due to the economic
policies.
The truth is that for decades,
France,
fully the ideology of Charles de Gaulle
man who led the country's economy as if
it was an army.
The goal was obsessed with protecting
French companies from the outside world,
but the world is different today and
macron wants a 180 degree shift from
this French economic theory.
His manifesto.
It was solid and it was rational.
He didn't promise any of those things
which are impossible to achieve once you
are in office and despite all of this,
you won by a landslide victory.
And that's not only in the presidential
elections,
but the parliamentary ones too.
And if this wasn't impressive enough,
he also did it against Marine Le Pen,
the champion of European populism prior
to the foundation of Mr macrons party or
marsh pollsters said Le Pen had the
victory guaranteed.
But macron prove them wrong.
Now we just asked him not to disappoint
us in 2018.
And in the meantime,
congratulations.
And annual.
Okay.
These were the 2017 visual political
wards.
I hope you enjoyed them.
And just before I say goodbye today,
I did want to wish you a happy 2018 and
thank you for joining us every week on
this channel.
So to everyone watching,
have a fantastic 2018 and I'll see you
next year.